let's move on to this uh situation up in
the great white north of canada as you
guys know there has been this massive
truck convoy basically driving across
canada uh sometimes people are saying
it's up upwards of 50 000 trucks people
protesting the draconian lockdowns and
mandates by the justin trudeau
government we've got some more info here
from the post-millennial prime minister
justin trudeau has reportedly been
whisked away to a secret location as a
convoy of truckers has descended on
ottawa to protest the government's
vaccine mandates the independent reports
that the trudeau family has left their
residence due to security concerns over
the truckers who are currently
gridlocking the city with their trucks
honking their horns and participating in
protests including singing the national
anthem outside parliament that does
sound scary
trudeau has reportedly been in isolation
after one of his children tested
positive for covid okay so let's be
clear you can sort of see and canada has
a very perverse version of this because
so much of their mainstream media is
state funded you can see that they're
shifting the narrative here already it's
not just people who are sick of masks
sick of mandates sick of lockdowns
saying hey we're going to all come
together and we're going to protest
which is your right and free western
democracies now it's they're blocking
things and you know trudeau kind of
called them racist and they're spreading
misinformation
and then trudeau had to go into hiding
because they want to make it seem like
these people are violent like they're
nazi adjacent etc etc well we've got
some video of those nazi adjacent people
as they arrived in ottawa and you tell
me what you see
[Music]
scary stuff isn't it they got to ottawa
they started dancing in the street there
were people and other people and they
were breathing on each other and smiling
and sharing joy and the desire to save
their country
freaking out over here my buddy ezra
levant from the rebel which is one of
the few independent media organizations
in canada he gave an absolutely
fantastic speech to the people of ottawa
we've got a little bit it is
almost as cold as justin trudeau's
hearts
because when people say what do we do
about the media
i say you become the media that's what
you do
[Music]
the media party it's
a subsidiary of the liberal party so
you've got to tell the story yourselves
everyone who is here
everyone who was along the road
has to bear witness and testify to what
they saw
because there's two competing narratives
the government says
you're racist
the government says texans the
government says you're violent
in the meantime
i've never seen a most diverse group of
canadians
but far from violence
people want to not be violated anymore
justin trudeau says you're extreme
but he's the one who has violated our
civil rights
[Music]
well that's a pretty bloody big fringe
tell them what happened
tell them what you saw
because they will not hear the truth
from anyone else
[Music]
that's freaking awesome i consider esla
ezra a friend he is a good man and that
is an inspirational speech by the way as
you know it's freezing in canada these
people would prefer
and as i mentioned on friday canadians
are pretty like calm and cool and
collected they would prefer to be inside
with a fire and some heating right but
they're out there saying we must fight
this evil insanity that is not stopping
that is closing our churches and our
schools and everything else he said a
couple things there and i want to quote
you become the media what a great line
guys all of you watching this
you are as powerful as the media you
know the media that has existed for a
long time maybe it was always lying to
us all all the time maybe it was i don't
know maybe it's only in the last
twenty ten five years that because of
technology we've been able to expose
them at the level so now it seems like
they lie about everything maybe they've
been lying way longer about way more
stuff than we thought
we can have some separate discussions
about that but every single one of you
have a have a brain you have an opinion
you have a life you have thoughts and
you have a phone and you can get those
things out there at least for now right
and we're working on the tech solutions
to make sure that you'll be able to do
it long term
but he's right you're the media just
because the new york times prints
something just because some rag up in
canada prints something doesn't mean
it's true and they're preying on the
fact that we're all afraid to talk to
each other that we're all afraid to say
what we really think and the more that
we don't say what we think the more that
they feel that they can encroach he then
went on to say you've got to tell the
story yourself i love that there's a
story happening in the world and as that
jordan peterson guy who i may be doing a
little something with tonight in miami
often would say wouldn't you want to be
the main character in your story
wouldn't isn't that the best thing to be
when you watch a movie it's usually
about the main character that's why the
word maine is there he's the driver of
the whole freaking thing well you got a
chance and then finally bear witness to
what you saw do not believe that because
the canadian media or the new york times
or cnn tells you that those people out
there are racists and bigots and sexists
and even anti-vaxxers or whatever
whatever ridiculous pejorative term they
want to use to describe those people who
have just been pushed far enough that
they had to create this convoy to drive
across a frozen tundra to get outside
and give speeches and dance with other
freedom loving people don't believe any
of the nonsense that they are pushing on
you on all of that and if you want to
bear witness how about we end this
segment with a little inspiration a
little music and here is what baron
witness looks like
[Music]
oh
[Music]
there ain't no way
this
[Music]
you is know us
[Music]
thinking awesome we're not going to take
it anymore that's what they did to the
good decent canadian the good decent
canadian who just wanted to live their
life they pushed them far enough that
this is what's going on so i just want
to be very clear about something i stand
with you good decent canadian i stand
with you against justin trudeau and all
of the people who have done this to you